so president donald trump has come to
the realization that he probably
needs fraud in order to win re-election
in november he needs to suppress the
vote in order to have a solid
shot at defeating joe biden and his
administration isn't even
hiding it anymore there's a new report
which i encourage you to read in
politico
explaining that trump's aides trump
staffers the people around him
know this and they're now looking at any
way they can come up with to suppress
the vote curb vote by mail
disenfranchise as many people as
possible
when they are people that are likely to
vote for joe biden rather than donald
trump now
you might remember last week i told you
we shouldn't be that confident in joe
biden's lead and that's true that hasn't
changed if you look at polls that have
biden up
nine and you see that there's a margin
of error of three and a half
that means joe biden might only be up by
two hillary won
by two in 2016 in the popular vote and
still lost the electoral college that
analysis from last week
is true and in particular if anything
changes between now and november that
helps donald trump a slightly improved
economy we'll talk about q3 gdp numbers
which we will get literally four days
before the election
um we could see a one or two point swing
away from biden and towards trump and
trump gets re-elected so that's all true
but it is also clear that it's too close
for comfort and the report in politico
points out that there is a complete and
total commitment from the trump campaign
to a strategy not of improving the
country not of improving the economy not
of dealing with coronavirus the strategy
is
essentially fraud to suppress the vote
so that the will of the people is not
accurately represented
this is not the type of fraud by the way
that they claim exists trump now has
spent
two three months i guess pushing the
idea that
there was in-person voter fraud back in
2016 and in 2020
there will be vote by mail fraud if more
people vote by mail remember
trump has not accepted the popular vote
result
of the 2016 election which had him
winning the presidency trump won
electorally in 2016.
he lost the popular vote by millions of
votes he still has not accepted that
and now he insists if we increase mail
in voting in 2020
it will be a fake fraudulent rigged
election the real there will be fraud
but the real fraud is what trump is
doing to suppress the vote
the real fraud is what trump is doing to
prevent vote by mail
and to kneecap the post office and we're
already seen seeing
bins of mail overflowing in post offices
across the country
as postal workers are restricted in
being able to work overtime to get the
mail delivered
if you want fraud in the sense of
someone preventing the will of the
people from being done
it's what donald trump and people around
him are doing and they have gone fully
masked off they're not even pretending
otherwise
and when you actually look at the full
list of what they're doing
it should be criminal now the if we want
to give trump a consequence
it's removing him in november right what
he's doing should be criminal but
i mean forget it right that's not going
to be uh
the way it's handled you've got a
massive effort in a bunch of states to
file lawsuits
to change voting rules when it comes to
vote by mail and voting absentee that
includes
minneapolis minnesota rather
pennsylvania
and nevada aides are trying to figure
out
what executive orders can trump sign
to just unilaterally curb mail in voting
through
any possible means they're looking at
how can they stop
mail-in ballots from being counted after
election day as many of you know
depending on state rules as long as the
postmark date of the mail-in ballot
is before the election or no later than
election day it would still be counted
and usually mail within states doesn't
take more than a couple of days to be
delivered and those vote
ballots would be counted in the couple
of days after election day trump is
looking to limit
that and trump is also looking according
to aides speaking to politico
trump is looking at could he tell the
postal service
not to deliver certain ballots that
states send out
all of this is on the table now here is
the really important
message a bunch of experts in voting
have looked at everything that they are
planning they've looked at all of these
ways
in which donald trump could suppress the
vote and they've come to the conclusion
that these techniques can only do so
much
in other words if you slow down mail
delivery
okay you can delay it but if people vote
early enough if you
send in your absentee ballot two three
weeks before the election it's going to
get there before election day even if
trump slows down the postal service to
some degree
a lot of this stuff is done at the state
and local level
so the takeaway is slowing down the mail
finding executive orders to hamper
delivery of mail-in ballot all of this
different stuff
it can only do so much and if we
overwhelm the vote
it's going to be more powerful than
anything trump can do
from what's been floated so far so yes
at the state and local level between now
and november we need to do everything we
can
to push governors and election officials
to run the election properly to not
allow these dirty tricks to actually
take hold
we need to do everything we can yes at
the federal level
we've got trump's postmaster general who
needs to continually be dragged before
uh house committees to testify and to be
put on the defensive about what he's
doing but he still might get away with
some of this stuff
but in the end the cumulative effect of
all of these techniques all of these
ideas
it can only do a little bit of
suppression if our turnout
is low it could hand the election to
donald trump
if our turnout is high it will not make
a difference if we
overwhelm the vote and that includes
when you can safely vote in person
doing it when you can vote by mail
sending in your ballot two three four
weeks
early meaning if it takes an extra five
days to be delivered it's not going to
be
uh a problem these techniques
cannot put trump back in the oval office
if if if if we vote and that's the good
news now
we also can't ignore the foreign
meddling
piece and that's what i want to talk
about next
this episode is sponsored by bluechew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable
with the same fda approved ingredient as
in viagra
and cialis it can be taken day or night
even on a full stomach since it's
chewable it works twice as fast as a
pill
whenever the opportunity arises blue
chew is prescribed online
by licensed doctors you don't have to go
to a doctor's office
you don't have to wait in line at a
pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discrete package they're made in
the usa and since blue chew prepares and
ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go
to bluetooth.com get your first shipment
free
when you use our promo code pacman
that's p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show